just saw Oppenheimer and Christopher
Nolan has a lot of expositional and
explanatory dialogue
what is on the nose Dialogue on the nose
dialogue is
dialogue that is generic
it is describing something that we could
easily see
that is clear in the scene
it's explaining something
um it's just kind of like lazy dialogue
that doesn't
show that character's voice
is there ever a time when it's okay to
write on the nose dialogue
every now and then you may have a
complicated sequence that you want to
help the reader check in and kind of
Orient themselves so you might have a
character say something you know
um
why did you bring you know I told you to
bring the red car why did you bring the
blue car you know
um so then that reminds the reader that
oh they switched cars back there
remember that you know so you might want
to plant something that is a bit on the
nose and you know I don't feel like a
writer should feel the pressure to write
you know sorkiness dialogue for every
single character
every single character doesn't have have
to have incredibly stylized dialogue
the show succession does
somehow they get away with it every
character is clever and makes Incredible
quips just off the top of their head and
every character has
um really genius put Downs of other
people but somehow it works on that show
but it doesn't work in most scripts
where
um you don't want your characters to
talk the same you definitely don't want
them to have the same style of dialogue
it can it be done almost if it's kind of
like making fun of itself
like kind of a self-reverential dialogue
or or almost trying to I don't even know
what the word would be but just certain
things that are just I wouldn't say
campy but you're trying to almost make
it a joke and so it's over the top on
the nose dialogue because it's sort of
like a joke on itself
I mean you could there's a
you know there's playing with
the genre or winking to the audience
that you might want to do
yeah it really I mean it really depends
on the material
sure
what if
you had said earlier that the character
should sound separate from each other
what if a writer is getting the note
that all of their characters are
sounding the same but they think no
these are all individuals I've gotten
that note too it's tough
um because when you read your own work
uh they seem distinctive but to other
people sometimes they don't uh
you can
it might help to write down Back stories
for your characters
um it helps to read it aloud it helps to
have a reading with friends I do
readings over Zoom now so it's really
easy to do
and just to hear it spoken out loud I
think does really help
but I think the main thing is to know
your character's goals and their wants
in general and then also in that
particular scene so then that will
inform how they speak you know if they
want this out of that other character
they would talk in this way you know
because they're trying to maybe sway the
other character
ideally the audience is in on that too
it knows their wants that was something
that David Mamet always said he said the
only thing an actor needs to know is
what they want in the scene and ideally
the audience knows that too
doesn't always have to be I mean maybe
you want to surprise us uh Breaking Bad
and Better Call Saul Vince Gilligan
um and the writers on those shows they
do a really interesting style of
Discovery where at the end of each scene
comes kind of like the reason why the
scene existed like it's that moment of
Discovery
um that we didn't see coming and that
that's truly the thing that advances the
story
before that there's just really
compelling character work you know and
compelling dialogue but at the end of
the scene
we realize oh that's what that's what he
meant when he said that earlier and
that's what they were going for and oh I
didn't see that coming there's some kind
of Discovery you know that's how Walt is
going to get out of this trap
um
you'll see it if you watch especially
Better Call Saul there's always that
kind of discovery that they build up to
in a scene and it's really great work
how does the character's internal and
external goal factor into their dialogue
it's very key for their dialogue it's
very important
um the in the external goal is their
action goal their physical goal that
they need to achieve kind of like the a
story goal
um maybe it's the most obvious or most
visual goal and then the internal like
it says it's going to be more emotional
it might be the love interest it might
be their family or it might be just kind
of a secondary active goal but it's not
as important as the um as the external
unless later they flip and maybe the
internal becomes more important than the
external if you know your character is
external and internal goal I think it's
really going to help you write your
dialogue because then you're writing
their dialogue to show what they want
and to get them actively toward their
goal you know
um we're Ascent I mean we're essentially
selfish people so when we speak it's
because we're trying to get somewhere
we're trying to get something you know
so it really helps to know their goals
what are your thoughts on monologues and
screenplays
don't make them too long
um
I mean I think maybe one or two long
dialogue passages uh are okay
but for especially for new writers you
don't want to have super super long
dialogue blocks and too many monologues
um
just saw Oppenheimer and Christopher
Nolan has a lot of expositional and
explanatory dialogue but it makes sense
because they're all scientists and
they're going back and forth about all
of these scientific topics and they're
just giving detail after detail
and it's you you are okay with it more
because visually he's a stunning
director you know the big screen
experience is important to him and I saw
in the theater and it is interesting to
watch but on the page I'm guessing
there's just it would just be so much
long long long Dialogue on the nose
dialogue scenes with so much Exposition
and I'd be like oh my god when are they
going to stop talking about fission
versus Fusion you know so a newer writer
who doesn't have that track record who
isn't known for something like Aaron
Sorkin might be known for monologues but
you're not so you really want to
um keep the dialogue as tight as
possible maybe with the
you know a few flourishes every now and
then maybe you do have a key monologue
um once or twice in your script that uh
ideally it captures theme it explores
the theme what your story is about
I didn't see Tai West's ex but I've
heard on Twitter I've seen people just
raving about I think her name was MIA
goth her her ending sort of monologue
and they just said yeah I've seen that
either okay yeah but I mean that's
tricky to end
a movie on a monologue and have it work
that is tough
um I actually have a client now he has a
very specific line he wants to end his
whole
feature screenplay with
and I don't think it works because I
think it's two on the nose and it's him
making a point
it feels like the writer is making a
point and I said it pulls me out you
know
um and we're supposed to feel good for
this character they have achieved their
goal they have come into themselves and
they are more confident now and we're
happy for that Arc
and then he has this last line in which
it's really negative he's like calling
out someone and basically you know
saying screw you and he likes it I don't
like it I think it's too negative
because it's a it's mainly a comedy the
script
so you know it's a tough endings are
tough but there's a film called
Barbarian also that was another low
budget horror film and I don't think
they really had a strong ending it just
evolved into kind of
um fighting you know just physical
blocking and I think it would have been
great if they had worked on the script
maybe a little bit longer and worked on
that ending